well today we're going to show you
something that has never been seen
before really centers around siphons
there we find siphons almost everywhere
you've probably seen a petrol siphon you
may have used a fish tanks - in fact you
probably use the siphon this morning
when you flush your toilet it really
started off as a bit of a special hobby
and you know Adrienne came up with the
ideas for an experiment which I agreed
to help him with because there was an
article published in a newspaper which
said that you know that somebody had
refuted the definition of a siphon it in
a dictionary and it's the Oxford English
Dictionary
this is a typical siphon what we have is
a container of liquid which is sort of
raised a little bit higher and then we
have another reservoir and we have a
connecting tube what we've done is we
filled this tube with liquid so there's
no air in it and so there's a continuous
flow of liquid and what's going to
happen is in a minute I'm going to pull
out the plug at the bottom this tube and
when I do that the water is going to
rush uphill and then it's going to come
down the top and fill up this beaker
down here what we can do is we can just
now pull that out and you can see the
level of this is decreasing the water is
going up here and how it's doing that is
it's going up over the tube there what
is going on there's a lot of confusion
about this and a lot of people have
assumed that what you're seeing here is
atmospheric pressure so so what they're
saying is that air molecules are forcing
down onto the top of the water here and
then that's then pushing the liquid up
the tube which is then going up to the
top here and then as the water goes down
this side it's dragging or reducing the
pressure and lifting the water over the
top and what we're going to show is that
isn't the case there's one problem here
and that's obviously you can't put water
into a vacuum but if you do it's just
going to boil away even really heavy
liquids like mercury have got a vapor
pressure so with it with the vacuums
that we've used mercury would also
distill or evaporate very very quickly
so what we've got here is a very special
kind of liquid that we make here and
it's called an ionic liquid
and ionic liquids are special because if
you put them in outer space they'll just
sit there happily year after year and it
won't boil away it'll just sit in the
beaker and nothing will happen to it and
that's pretty unusual this means that if
I spill an ionic liquid on my bench
it'll still be there when I die we can
think of an ionic liquid imagine we've
got a little bar magnet well that's one
molecule or our ionic liquid and if we
get another little bar magnet and stick
them together they stick quite well and
if you get a whole chain of these
magnets pulling them apart it's quite
difficult but actually you can still
move them around but just separating
them is the hard part and that's how the
ionic liquid works so it's just like
lots of little bar magnets moving freely
around but stuck really well to each
other here we've got our two reservoirs
in this case we've set them up both the
same level and the reason we've done
that is because obviously in a vacuum
there's still a lot of air trapped in
that liquid and so what we do is we get
rid of all that air because if that air
forms a bubble then it breaks the bonds
in between these molecules and we don't
want that we want them to stick together
and this is now really ultra high vacuum
so the pressure we're talking about here
is kind of like low atmospheres we're
not quite at the space station here but
if you jumped out with your spacesuit
you're going to look kind of like that
aliens or a monster exploding outside
the spaceship so there really is no air
of any significance in this chamber at
all well yeah we did the experiment
because we were intrigued and it was an
experiment that we could do we're really
really quite easily we have the vacuum
equipment and we have the liquids that
are required so it really was a happy
marriage of all of these components
within our research group so what we're
gonna do now is we're gonna lift this
tube so if you remember the idea of a
siphon is to take the liquid above the
level of the reservoir and so there's
two things that could happen here either
the liquids going to hold together in
which case we can then tip from one
content the other or the liquids just
gonna not do anything and it's just
going to flow back down it's just gonna
leave a vacuum in the tube and a big
hole so we're not going to see anything
going on at all we're just gonna pull on
this lever here and this is going to
move the tube
all the way up and now we're coming
level with the top of the liquid and now
as we come beyond the level of the
liquid and you can see now that as I
lift that higher and higher that that
tube is now clearly above the level of
liquid so the only reason that liquid is
held in that tube is because the
molecules are actually stuck together
they can't pull themselves apart to
create a vacuum now all we have to do is
to show that the siphon really does work
in a vacuum is just change the level of
containers so we're going to push in
this little lever here and there we go
and gradually I don't know if you caught
that the liquid flue was flown from one
contains the other can we could this
that's the miracle of this design we can
actually just keep doing this and we can
just go all the way back again and
liquid just flowing backwards and
forwards and see each time we do this so
this is a siphon in a vacuum so what
you're seeing here is the liquid is
actually being pulled up and over
there's no air to pushing that so
there's no atmosphere that's doing any
work here what's going on is molecular
cohesion and gravity so what we can say
is actually its suction well I have to
thought you know it's pretty clear that
the atmospheric pressure really isn't
important in the functioning of a siphon
what is important in the function the
functioning of a siphon is the cohesive
energy that so the stickiness of the
liquid so that it sticks together and it
doesn't break apart torn droplets which
is a function of the surface tension but
also this amazing force which surrounds
us which is gravity so our experiments
which were carried out in vacuums of the
order of 10 to the minus 5 millibars
which is incredible vacuum really
compared to to to more traditional
experiments have shown that atmospheric
pressure really isn't required actually
what we can say here is siphons really
suck